Randy, I think we need
to have a talk.
No time to talk.
The agricultural inspector's
about to drop by.
Once we get certified from him,
we can start selling
like a real farm.
Have patience wife.
Soon our fortunes will change.
Oh that must be him now.
Yes, I'm with the state
testing board.
Is this Tegrity Farms?
Name's right there on the sign.
Come on back.
So with this festing device,
I can check not only
the TAC levels in your product,
but also detect any impurities
and give you a final score
based on overall
chemical makeup.
Yep, that's good shit.
Now let me test the levels
in your organic house blend.
Yep, that's good shit.
Now what about
the Tegrity Jungle Bud?
Let's test it out.
Whoa.
Yeah?
Whoa. Yeah!
I don't know what Tegrity is,
but that is some good shit.
All right!